and love thank you guys for for
enjoining uh my talk this morning this
is gonna be a cell biology talk so my
name is uh
Sabri scare yay I am an assistant excuse
me an associate professor of biology at
Millsaps College Millsaps College is a
small liberal arts college in Jackson
Mississippi we have all undergraduates
and our institution and so all the work
I'm going to be presenting today is work
done by four-year undergraduate students
at Millsaps College so the title of my
talk is understanding the regulation of
membrane curvature during mating it
tetrahymena thermophilus and there's a
lot of words in there we're gonna unpack
this over the course of this talk so let
me give you a brief outline of what
we're gonna do today so first we're
gonna talk about we're gonna introduce
the concept of membrane curvature really
sort of what are the physiological
functions and sort of how that is
membrane curvature in chief next we'll
talk about the role of membrane
curvature in cell cell fusion or really
how we're gonna unpack that over the
course of this talk then we'll talk
about how we're using tetrahymena as a
model for cell cell fusion and the role
of this protein called reticulum in the
process next we'll talk about
tetrahymena thermophilus as a model for
studying otology okay and then we'll
finally sort of end on discussion
talking about the potential role of this
protein called snakes for in regulating
a special form of autopsy cost elective
autography
in mating in tetrahymena the maxilla
okay
so let's discuss briefly sort of the
mechanisms and functions of membrane
curvature so before we get into
mechanisms let's just talk about why we
might study
membrane curvature well so one of the
things that is really important to
understand is that cells have to take on
dynamic shapes during their life process
and depending on the physiological
function of their selves those shape
changes can be pretty diverse and so if
you're a lymphocyte and you need to
travel to a site of infection the cell
morphology has to change completely to
facilitate the migration of that cell
well membrane curvature is gonna
underline the the shape change that
underlies the movement of that cell okay
we can have changes in a membrane shape
during the formation of organelles such
as the mitochondria the endoplasmic
reticulum and Golgi apparatus okay we
can also have small changes in membrane
shape that regulate the movement the
removal of proteins of the membranes of
cells of in a process called endocytosis
we can also have the fusion of two
membranes okay and this is one of the
processes we're gonna focus on these oh
so we can have the fusion of two
membranes or processes called exocytosis
or the secretion of vesicles from
eukaryotic cells okay or we can even
have two host cells fuse they mess with
topic I wanna sort of unpack in the
first part of this lecture though the
process of two cells using is called
cell cell fusion okay and this turns out
to be a pretty important process for a
number of physiological processes one
example of an important physiological
process is viral infection
so when viruses need to get inside of
their whole selves of the membrane the
boundary between the outside of that
virus and the outside of the cell fuse
in a lab for the entry of genetic
material from the virus into the host
cell you can also have fusion of somatic
cells so you can imagine that two
precursors views the form of
multinucleated by fibro ok
multinucleated puzzle and this happens
with other forms of of tissue including
bone okay and of course the fusion that
gave rise to us right a fusion of
gametes fusion of sperm and egg okay so
in all of these processes but memories
go undergo dramatic shape changes and
it's these changes in shape they try a
diffusion of these two cells so how do
you shape these member so javi the
membrane shape well there's two ways in
which or two broad categories by which
membranes are shaped in one category you
have proteins that are actually
manipulating the membrane okay you can
have proteins that is bent themselves in
the membrane it changed the lipid
packing you have proteins that alig
arise on the membrane that is they they
touch each other it's not to shape the
membrane as those protein growing than
that right and then you can also have
lipids okay that that can be inserted
into the membrane can change the
relative packet okay so it turns out
that one of the things that regulates
cell cell fusion or proteins called few
surges that bring membranes in really
close proximity leading to the infusion
but one of the things that my lab has
been really curious about is how do
lipids play a role in accommodating or
shaping their fusion that's induced by
protein okay so what we're really gonna
focus on at least the initial part of
this talk is the potential role of
lipids in regulating cell cell fusion so
lipids can dictate or or accommodate a
fusion based on their geometry so if you
recall phospholipids which make a
cellular membrane have a phosphate head
hydrophobic tails okay long fatty acid
tails okay
and it's the relative size of that head
group versus
the tale that dictates the geometry of
the lipid so you can see in a here you
have a phosphatidylcholine or a
cylindrical lipid which means that the
relative size of the phospholipid head
compared to the two tails Lisa sort of
this straight down molecule in the shape
of a cylinder so when these are packed
in a membrane they lead to a very flat
sheet in other words they lead to a zero
curvature no curvature occurring in the
membrane but if you look at the liquids
below that those lipids have a different
geometry they have a maybe a smaller
head group in one tail or a small head
group in two tails and those lead to
different geometry so the the lipid here
l pc lie so phosphatidylcholine
has a large head group minister and a
single fatty acid table and as their
fourth takes on the shape of an inverted
cone and it turns out if you pack a
bunch of LPC in a membrane you start to
induce curvature that's juror that's
determined by the leaflet that that
lipid is inserted in so why are we
talking about this well it turns out
people have looked at the effect of
adding LPC into viral fusion preparation
and so what you're looking at here on
the y-axis is since this your formation
so that is a way to sis you are these
big conglomerates of fuses okay and on
the x-axis you see the addition of
various various user genic fuser genic
protein so h8 is a viral protein that
will lead to cell cell fusion okay so
what you see is that when you add a
chain so that's the plus sign you see an
increase in success here for me and this
is a this can be facilitated by changes
the pH that's not really the point right
now but the point is you get huge it
when you add a viral when you add this
viral protein okay so what happens if
you add a lipid that should have some
effect on curvature like
see well what you see is when you add
LPC to the inner leaflet you block the
fusion that is induced by H a okay this
suggests that the lipids present in a
membrane can affect the ability of cells
to fuse
okay so we asked we we were sort of
interested in the question of there's
the lipid content of a particular
membrane so let me back up and say that
what you're looking at here is the
exogenous edition of MPC okay so our
question is is the endogenous level
there are the endogenous levels of lipid
regularly they tell facilitates themself
huge yeah so to get it this question we
wanted to use tetrahymena thermophilus
of models so let me set up the model
first and I'll tell you why we think
it's a it's why we why we particularly
chose it but they specifically so
Tetrahymena normally undergo cell cell
fusion when they're in the star state so
in a you're looking at two free-swimming
Tetrahymena so these are highly ciliated
eukaryotic organisms okay and these are
in well-fed conditions and what you can
see that that that entire only chase
cell is covered in these hair like
Sylvia okay but it B what happens is
when the cells are starved and mixed
with tetrahymena a different mating type
those cilia are cleared from the very
anterior portion of the cell and those
two cells to come together to mate okay
and what's gonna happen in this mating
process is there's a fusion pore that's
gonna get expanded large enough so that
the two the two mating tetrahymena can
exchange nuclei between them okay and
that's sort of what this crude schema is
showing here so Tetrahymena have two
nuclei so you can see in a you have this
really tiny nuclei in black bear that's
called a micro nucleus okay and a blue
the
you have a larger nuclei called a
backrub okay so it turns out that the
micro nucleus is the comedic nucleus
it's per it's purely there to be
transmitted during during a sexual
reproduction okay that nuclei is
transcriptionally inactive so it doesn't
contribute directly to the protein that
will ultimately give rise to the
phenotype of that Tetrahymena okay what
it does do is provide the DNA that
generates the larger macro loop okay and
that macro nucleus is transcriptionally
active okay and therefore will
ultimately lead to producing the
proteins that give rise to the phenotype
demonstrated by the Tetrahymena so what
happens during to drive the conjugation
or the mating process is that
micronucleus device goes through several
division okay and that's what we're
seeing there is beat right so those two
origin ooh CLIA on the results of
several divisions that occurred in that
black microdude okay that ol
micronucleus is destroyed evidence and
the products from division from the
division of that micro nuclei are
exchanged one of those micro nuclei
stays in in its host cell okay and the
other copy of that might could look like
gets exchanged with its mating partner
and that's what you're seeing it deep
okay so essentially what's happening at
the junction between those two cell he
is a bunch of memory fusion and then the
expansion of pause they facilitate the
exchange of those micro cuvette and so
we think we can use that the of the news
and events at the conjugation Junction
looking at the junction between those
mating types to get at that question of
how an lipids regulating cell cell fused
so why so why do we think we can use
that particular fact that fusion event
as a model well there's a beautiful
paper published in in a 2010 from the
new a group of Penn State where they use
mass spectrometry imaging to look at the
lipids that are at the conjugation
juncture the Vedic Tetrahymena and what
they found was something very
interesting
essentially what they found is that as
fusion occurs okay as future the curd
that the conjugation injunction that
there was a decrease in the levels of
phosphatidylcholine and an increase in
the levels of phosphatidyl ethanolamine
last versatile choline is a symmetrical
curvature is this thing limping and five
total anthoula B is a is a cool shape
curvature accommodating lipid and so
once we saw this this data we really
asked ourselves is this a regulated
process in other words is the cell
actively regulating its with the content
promote more accommodate fusion and if
so how is it being regulated okay so one
of the ways this these B's a lipid
continent this conjugation junctions
might be regulating is through the
activity of lipid transfer proteins that
act at the interface between two
vertebrae and so what you're seeing here
is an image of a lipid transfer protein
in blue that's swapping out a lipid from
the green membrane and adding it to the
yellow okay so what might be the sites
of membrane junctions okay the one side
of membrane exchange junctions could be
probably the most loyal character one of
the most well characterized sites on
endoplasmic reticulum plants of membrane
sites okay part of the reasons these are
really well characterizes because people
who are scientists that are really
interested in it
calcium induce counselor release okay
look at the on the entrance of calcium
from the extracellular space into the
endoplasmic reticulum through a bunch of
calcium channels that act at these
interface
okay so the point is is that liquid
transfer proteins could regulate the
trick the exchange of lipids at a
membrane memory interfaces endoplasmic
reticulum plasma membrane are the well
studied and well characterized membrane
interfaces okay and and so we were
curious if these junctions is ER plasma
membrane junctions might be involved in
in lipid exchange in Tetrahymena and one
of the things I should say that's
important they say no one's
characterized um ER plasma membrane
contact sites in their role in cell cell
fusion so a 2015 in collaboration with
Eric Holder who at st. Olaf College in
Minnesota we conducted a study where we
wanted to look at the membrane dynamics
that occur during
tetrahymena a mating and tetrahymena
during conjugation to tetrahymena and so
what you're looking at is c is an
electron tomography
reconstruction okay of mating
Tetrahymena so in the upper part of that
panel next to the label C you're looking
at one tetrahymena and then on the
bottom panel of that of that particular
image we're looking at another tetra and
that green line there represents the the
membrane that's being shared by these
two using Tetrahymena okay so one of the
things i was interesting here is you can
see that light blue wispy membrane is
invading these spaces in the memories of
these of the fusion point that result
from the the fusion of the two membranes
okay and the other particular membrane I
want to point out here is this membrane
right here in blue my memory and in blue
is the nuclear membrane okay and as we
started to look through our images when
we know this was that this blue membrane
was also making content
with the plans of memory as you know the
endoplasmic reticulum membrane is
continuous okay with the nuclear
membrane and so we hypothesized that
this this wispy membrane that's
extending of the nucleus and coming into
contact with the with the plasma
membrane it might represent an ER plans
on their brain Junction we couple this
to some some Calibri experiments that
we've done using small molecule
inhibitors to inhibit lipid transfer
ensuring they don't smell like small
molecule inhibitors in pair pair
formation we basically came up with a
hypothesis and our hypothesis was that
pair formation itself so fusion is
mediated by liquid transfer between ER
plasma membrane contact sites and at the
formation of these contacts Isis
dependent on ER endoplasmic reticulum
tubule a ship okay okay so to begin to
test this we wanted to find we will
attack there define whether there could
be proteins that are expressed in
tetrahymena that might lead to the
tribulation extension of this blue
membrane that we just highlighted so
there are proteins that are very well
characterized that are known to to be
lame embryos to be linear our member
aenthul procedure called reticulum
protein and essentially those proteins
have how famous is that embedded in the
membrane of the ER and when there are
enough of those reticulum proteins in an
ER membrane they could deform the
membrane into a tube okay so what we did
was we took a bioinformatics approach to
try to identify if there were reticulum
proteins that were expressed in
tetrahymena
so to do that we searched
NCBI for Tetrahymena protein that will
abolish the real particular protein
samples we then took the proteins that
founded Tetrahymena and ran them through
a program called HH print which allows
you to compare secondary structure and
amino acid identity to node to actual
crystal structures or NMR structures of
previously characterized proteins and so
it's a really powerful way for you to
want to do homology studies ok so once
we confirmed that the proteins that we
found at tetrahymena were indeed a
particular protein we then use the
Tetrahymena gene expression database to
look to see at what point in the 10
having a life cycle is this particular
reticulum seen Express here's what we
found
so what you're looking at on the y-axis
are normalized expression units okay
what you're looking at on the x-axis is
the life stage of the Tetrahymena so
essentially what we're looking at here
is when during the life stage of
Tetrahymena it's the reticular mRNA
expressed the L here stands for long
face oh these are went tetrahymena going
really robustly S stands for starvation
after having they need to stop before
they can be mated in a laboratory ok so
when we start so so S stands for
starvation and C stands for conjugation
so this is the during the tea time at
the Vedic period and what you can see is
that there's a big spike in reticulan
expression very early during conjugation
and this would be consistent with a
protein that plays a role in it so they
sell cell fusion okay so we now know
that reticulum is expressed in in
Tetrahymena and so now what we would
like this what we wanted to see with
those reticulum protein localized to the
conjugation Junction
so to do this what we were what we play
will be what we did was we went into
endogenously tag ridiculous so we wanted
to few GFP
we wanted to add GFP to the endogenous
chromosome the tetrahymena in which the
reticulum G resides so to do this we're
gonna use a we use the plasmid that
allows us to close upstream and
downstream flanking sequences of the
reticular G next to three fluorescent
protein a promoter called MTT one that
can be reducible that's driving the
expression of a drug resistance marker
and so what this will allow us to do is
to select four four four cells then
actually have this DNA inserted in the
chromosome by treating it with this with
this drug this particular team provides
resistance to a drug called a liberal
bias it okay so how do we get this in
the cell where we use a ballistic
bombardment and essentially what this
means is we take DNA that we linearize
okay we coated only coat gold particles
with that DNA and then we can use this
gene gun to basically shoot these gold
code in DNA particles into tetrahymena
and what we what we hope will happen is
that if we flanked this particular
consent with DNA nearly the the
reticular gene in this case if we're
trying to tag it the very end of the
three prime coding sequence on the one
side and they have the three prime
untranslated region on the other that we
get then add the EGF pftt one and do
four to the very c-terminus of of that
particular gene the three prime end of
that particular gene through homologous
recombination and so our goal is to
create an ounce
thank reticulan using this method and
I'm not going to show you this but if we
just exchange the 3-prime coding
sequence for the 500 utr then we can
replace the whole coding sequence of
reticulum this way and generate
knockouts this way okay so we use this
method to generate gfp-tagged reticulum
so here you're looking at mating
tetrahymena and you can see that there
seems to be some so in this control cell
which doesn't have GFP we're getting
some bleed through of nuclear stain into
the GFP Channel okay that's why you see
two dots there that are showing the
nuclei Hertz there's a nuclear stage so
that's actually staining the micro and
macro nutrient and then you see the
merge there so these are control
condition unlabeled condition but we
look at reticulum GMP expressing cells
what you see is that you see in the in
the GFP Channel
you see staining at the very at right at
the junction okay and then you also see
some nuclear staining okay or some
staining of something around the nucleus
to see that let's look at a higher
magnification example so again here you
see the micro nucleus the nuclear
envelope perhaps or some membrane around
the micronucleus big label and they also
you also see labeling at the junction as
well as these tubular like structures
okay so essentially what this looks like
to us is that reticulum labeled the
conjugation Junction so that membrane
between okay between the two mating
cells it also seems to the label so
membranes that that are staining the
very periphery of the nucleus so this is
really consistent with labeling the
endoplasmic reticulum okay so then what
we wanted to do is we wanted to generate
some knock out some Tetrahymena
knockouts to see to look
the effects of removing reticulum on
tetrahymena bathing so in the top panel
here in lanes one in five you're looking
at while are you looking at a wild-type
cells expressing reticular in lanes two
three six and seven you're looking at
tetrahymena knock out cell and you see
that those cells do not express
reticular if you're looking at the top
panel if you look at the bottom panel
what we're doing there is we've done
rt-pcr for the drug resistant marker
that we inserted in order to generate
the knockouts that you can see that only
the knockout cells are expressing the
drug resistance marker so it looks like
we indeed have
tetrahymena knockout cells here so the
first so what we wanted to look at with
regards to the knockout was in
particular that the conjugation junction
and we're arguing that you need er
tribulation to lead to lipid exchange to
facilitate the diffusion that mediates
mating okay we wanted to look at what
the effect of knocking out reticulum was
on the formation of these pairs that are
required to perform during conjugation
so in the top panel here you're looking
at controlled conditions and what you
can see is we have quite a bit of quite
a bit of mating okay so you can see all
these these tetrahymena existing in
these these pairs okay but when we look
at when we look at mating in particular
knockouts what we see is a real
reduction in the number of paths okay
and we quantify that here and so on so
what we see here and and I'll just
conclude this first part of this talk so
what you see here is that endogenous
reticulum labels the conjugation
junction as well as the nuclear
periphery so again man nuclear
peripheral staining is some of that
tubules daily we saw in those images is
really consistent with labeling the
endoplasmic reticulum and it's also
really interesting that that then we
also see labeling of the conjugation
junction again supporting the idea
they're mainly these could be signs of
them these could be membrane context I
mean importantly when we delete
reticulum
we see an impairment in an empirical
amazing again suggesting that that
reticulum may be required for
tetrahymena convocation so in terms of
future directions for it but this part
of the talk we want to develop both for
instance marking so now we can actually
visualize Cole visualize the endoplasmic
reticulum and reticular and in
tetrahedral we also would like to
perform structure function analysis the
data to determine which domains on
reticulum are required for this this
function at the conjugation touch we
also like to begin to look at proteins
that interact with reticulum with the
hopes of identifying a lipid transfer
protein that could support our
hypothesis that lipid transfer is
mediating the ability to diffuse during
Teti having a baby okay
so what we're gonna do now is we're
gonna switch gears to another
physiological process that we're really
interested in spending in the land and
that physiological process is otology so
in this particular image you're looking
at organelles shaping as a process
that's ends up as a set of processes
that are dependent on membrane curvature
and one of one of one of the really good
examples of something that we think is
regulated by membrane curvature is the
formation of this organelle called the
auto factory okay so all the phagosome
is formed during a process called autop
adji and on top of G is a process in
which the cell begins to eat itself
under starvation conditions so perhaps
the best characterized starvation
condition is with sales are missing
amino acids
and essentially what will happen is that
a double line membrane okay will form
typically near the ER but we're saying
now that they can form from a lot of
different areas and essentially what
happens is this this this double line
membrane called the bagger for okay wool
will form in the cytoplasm and expand
through membrane deformations in
membrane fusion around whatever cargo is
near it in the side of plant when that
when that when this membrane expands and
encloses that particular congress called
an auto phagosome okay and essentially
what will happen is is that that auto
phagosome will fuse with lysosomes and
the lysosomes will lead to the
degradation of that material and the
repurposing of it for essential
functions so there's the idea behind
using ontology to stop condition well it
turns out that as you might expect that
otology is really of is associated with
a number of disease states a bunch
listed here but one of the one of the
things I'm interesting when considering
how article G relates to diseases that
both the up regulation of otology in the
down-regulation of autopsy suggests that
are both associated with disease but
they're but the fact that both the
increased and decreased levels of our
cafeterias okay with disease to check
that there must be some basal level of
autopsy that's occurring all the time
and so so where we were we where we know
now that otology isn't only occurring
under starvation condition but it is
part of a maintenance program that's
that's done by the cell now the other
function that surrounded photography is
that not only is it something that's
happening all the time but in some ways
it can be weaponized that is to say that
that normally auto phagosome engulf
things that are near them is sort of a
non-discriminatory okay
but in this weaponization you can all
the phagosome can be specifically
targeted to selective cargo okay so in
this example here what you see is that
there is a cargo and interacts with a
receptor and that receptor tense can
interact with proteins that on the but
on the other backers own membrane but
the protein being highlighted here is a
person called a TGA on lc3 okay so there
are receptors that bind lc3
and lead to the car lead to the specific
degradation of that cargo there are
great examples of this and the release
to the degradation of damaged
mitochondria expressing receptors that
can engulfed by the other phagosome and
so this kind of autocracy base on top of
g of specific target is called selective
or topic and it turns out that selective
art averaging has been associated with a
number of of cardio metabolic diseases
at them and as I said no sense colleges
in Jackson Mississippi and understanding
how metabolism is regulated something
that's really important to this thing
that we have a population that's really
affected by things such as obesity and
diabetes it's a really understanding
selective otology is important to us a
bit in the sustain okay so as you might
imagine we can use tetrahymena to study
this specific problem as well and the
reason tetrahymena is a really good
model for this problem is because the
the micro nuclei like those little
nuclei better exchange of during
tetrahymena mating remember only are
only you're meeting with that they are
transcriptionally inactive and so in
order for the phenotype of these cells
to change under this foundation
condition under which they're mating
they have to make new macro nuclei and
the way new macro nuclei are developed
is by several divisions from the micro
nuclei that
were exchanged between the Tetrahymena
within this mating program okay so oh oh
I should say from the fusion of the
exchanged nuclei that were exchanged
during this morning program and so what
essentially happens as you can see and
he is that you get to from the
development of the comedic fusion of
those of the two nuclei what you get is
two light blue macro nuclei macro nuclei
and those two little pig new micro
nuclei and so what ends up happening
what ends up having to happen for these
cells to gain a new phenotype is they
they have to destroy the old macro new
glee and that's highlighted here in the
red box that might that macro nucleus is
labeled in green because we know mega
died well because I made the cartoon
that way but the reason I labeled in
green is because there's been a wealth
of evidence and Tetrahymena that the Mac
the old macro nucleus that gets
destroyed and in order to be cells to
gain the new phenotype are coded with
all the phagosome okay and the reason we
know that is because there's been some
really good work that is showed that a
tg8 GFP ATG is being a phagosome of
protein labels these macro nuclei and
deletion of a kinase VPS 34 that's
required to make the other phagosome
this rust is this degradation completely
okay so the fact that this single
nucleus gets to me the degradation or
ecology provides a 3d model first
asperity selectively on top of G of this
nuclear all right so the approach we've
taken the study this is to characterize
a protein they may play a room in
shaping the other factors on that this
protein is a kind of protein called a
bar protein the two specifically a
snicks bar per
and that's highlighted here in yellow
okay so why did we choose to focus on
the snakes poppers
well it turns out that in Tetrahymena
there's a there they're a gene that
maybe co-expressed
that is to say that there are genes that
have very similar patterns of expression
and so when we when we were
characterizing Reticulans expression
what we noticed was that there was
another gene this gene T therm zero zero
two one nine three zero zero okay that
had the same expression pattern as
reticulum and so essentially what we did
was we we wanted to see if this gene
might be playing a role in conjugation
just like we think ridiculous so when we
looked at this gene what we found is
that this gene has significant homology
to a yeast protein called snicks four
okay and it turns out that the what
snakes four does it snakes for it's
required for the trafficking of enzymes
of to the vacuole of mating yeast and it
turns out the vesicle the transporter
that brings these enzymes to the vacuole
is it essentially an auto phagosome and
so the trafficking of this enzyme to the
to the vacuole is in a sort of a form of
selected or topic and it turns out that
if you knock out snakes for in yeast
that you disrupt this really is the CVT
pathway or this this is selectively our
topic you like badly and so we ask what
might this snakes for be doing in
tetrahymena so we created we generated
GFP snakes for expressing tetrahymena
and we looked at where they look alive
during mating and I'm leaving off some
data here but for the purposes of
privity so in this type panel here
you're looking at non GFP expressing to
traverse a wild-type expressing tetra
happen in the first panel you see GFP in
the second panel you see lights
attractor and what lights will tracker
does
distract the lysosome okay so remember
what happens in the formation of an auto
phagosome auto faggins engulf a condom
then lysosomes fuse with that other
phagosome converting into all the
lysosome decorating their material
that's inside the other Factory
so the third planet you're looking at
Hurst and what that showing is all the
nuclei on itself and what you notice is
that the nuclei at the very back of this
cell
okay are labeled with like so tracker
that nuclear the very back of the cell
is is the parental macro nucleus the OL
micronucleus that must be degraded so
remember now there are five nuclei on
each of those cells yet only one of
those cells is life attract a positive
okay so again this is a very selective
degradation of this nucleus but we look
at this process in when we look at where
to try I'm gonna snakes for the
gfp-tagged version of tetra mystics for
is at this time in tetrahymena mating is
what we see we see that in the first
panel you can see they tetrahymena
snakes for is labeling that nucleus in
the back that's the same nucleus next
lights attract of positive and you know
it's a nucleus because it's also a Hertz
positive we can see that in this next
panel so what we see is that the lights
attract a positive nucleus is the only
nucleus that snakes for positive what
does this suggest this next four is
associated with the degrading macro
nucleus the macro nucleus they're
specifically targeted for our top foot
for our topic okay interestingly we see
some lysosomes
okay that aren't just adjacent to GFP
positive some give people positive echo
vesicle suggesting that snakes for and
the light so tracker arrived
independently to the nucleus which would
also be consistent with being Auto
phagosome so we wanted to know if the
local
zatia of sneaks forward to this
degrading macro nucleus with dependent
on other faculty and so what we did was
we looked at when the snakes for would
localize to the nucleus in the presence
of three ma which should inhibit all the
factors on the formation so essentially
what we're saying is if there are no
other factors amongst the snakes for
localized to the degrading to the to the
macro nucleus the Olmecs so in the top
panel you're looking at tetra
tetrahymena snakes for GFP on the first
panel Thank You panel ISO tracker third
panel hurts and the fourth panel merge
and you can see that Tetrahymena sticks
for GFP like we expect is localizing
there's a light subtract of positive
nucleus in the back of itself but when
we treat with three MA when we see a
reduction in life so tracker in that
nucleus in the back of the cell we also
see a loss of
tetrahymena sticks for localization to
that quickly you see that let's look at
the higher mag image so again you can
see on the top third the co-localization
between snakes for life so tracker and
the nucleus stain in the back of the
cell and on the 3m a treated cells you
see a complete loss of localization to
that nucleus suggesting that that
tetrahymena snakes for is a label that
labeling the metal macro nucleus in an
auto factors on dependent manner so we
generated sticks for knockout cell and
we were interested to see if we would
see a defect in our top of giametta
nucleus it selectively on top of that
all that little bit so in this top panel
you seen a wild-type wild-type meetings
okay we're seeing that that nucleus in
the back of the cell is license records
okay we see in the second panel that
hurts
is there something nucleus so that is
indeed a nucleus that's being labeled
and in the merger
sea-coal organization of life's
attractor in the nucleus limiters when
we do this when we do the same
experiment in snakes for knockouts
interestingly we did not see a loss of
life so tracker positivity in that
nucleus they met old micro nuclear
remember the idea would be that if
snicks war wasn't there then there would
be no no all the phagosome imprisoned on
the membrane if there's no other factors
on present there shouldn't be any lights
or tracker
there's no ecology so we were surprised
to see that those nuclei were still nice
attract a positive but then we looked at
the actual size of the nuclei and when
we saw was there the knockout
Tetrahymena knockout then the macro
nuclei in the kitchen I'm gonna knock
out cell was significantly larger when
compared to the wild type cell okay and
that's quantified here so that was sort
of interesting because there's been some
evidence that that there are degra the
grating enzymes that are trafficked
independent of lysosomes to the
degrading micronucleus the other
phagosome that are consumed our other
packages that consume mitochondria and
so we're we're interested in exploring
whether this this this effect on nuclear
size is due to miss localization of
mitochondrial enzymes that end up in
this so in conclusion
tetrahymena snakes for labels the
degrading macro nucleus this labeling
and disrupted by impairing all of the
phagosome formation and the deletion of
snakes for correlates with launch a
nuclear so future experiments that we
want to go there are additional snakes
for family members and thank a yeast to
see more robust phenotypes particularly
in my topper G in autography of the
mitochondria one needs to delete snakes
for and it's
it's all the premier's Asian politics 41
and 642 in order to see a really strong
phenotype so we wonder who in that same
compensation by the other makes family
members in terms of the light source of
localization the other thing we like to
do is read ideally we really love to
characterize the the the receptors that
are leading to the targeting of the auto
phagosome and so one of the things we'd
like to do is use by ID tagging up
sticks for to identify protein manner in
the periphery of the trading back
critically and where future direction
that isn't up here is we love to make
mutations for snakes for that would
impair snakes plausibility to bind to
end or vein membrane to see if that
activity is required for its effects
deprivation of so I'd love to
acknowledge one of the students that
have done this work there's a lot of
undergrads here the names I won't
I won't name them but we've done many of
these experiments both in my research
lab but also in my in some of the
laboratory classes that I've taught here
at Millsaps I look to thank our
collaborators including the tetrahymena
Stein Center at Cornell University which
helped us to make some of the cell lines
that we showed in this presentation the
Turku is lab at the University of
Chicago the Kapler lab it takes this am
and someone that is in here which is the
cilia genomics consortium which has been
an invaluable resource to me and my
students in terms of funding I'd like to
thank the Howard Hughes Medical
Institute for grant that we have here at
no sense that it's funner than a lot of
this work and Mississippi in break rank
for funding this work I'm gonna be
taking questions
by email and I really encourage you to
to email the questions well I'll get the
questions by email and I'll be able to
respond to you as soon as possible I'm
looking forward to hearing your thoughts
and and looking for ways that we can get
at some really some really cool
questions here with this work thank you